je vais la laisser
angers une grande aventure les appels
encore nos héros sont à la recherche de
la troisième reliques qui leur permettra
de retrouver le docteur simon
il arrive au japon en 250
je suis déjà allé au japon l'été dernier
pour mes vacances les j'aurais été d'une
gentillesse incroyable
en même temps il n'y avait pas de
dangereux guerrier samouraï de l'époque
féodale
je vous laisse avec la suite de
l'aventuré pendant que je me sers avait
donc c'est lui le choc on dit chez moi
quand je préfère dire shôgun ce puisque
très bien face à ce fait j'ai ici on du
show grille mais ça dépend des régions
et ensuite comment il faut apparu dans
montalet être fou des sites non on était
des amis dans ce cas là ça va tu
attendais
on est des esprits des amis et des
esprits des esprits pote quoi aux biens
dans ce cas vous êtes déjà mort et vous
ne pouvez pas s'offrir
c'est un truc qui vous aurait été donné
par quelqu'un en blouse blanche voulait
garder de la relique ancestrale confiée
par le grand esprit on monte aussi blanc
que la cime du mont fucci rendre fou
jamais je ne vous donnerai la relique
ancestrale confiée par le grand esprit
augmentons aussi blanc que la cime de
membres
donnez nous la relique ou alors je vous
dis tous quel rôle il parle et vous met
la relique quoi le truc dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est vrai il
faudra être plus précis on a plein de
drôles et les cuisses et la relique
ancestrale confiée par le vent esprits
au manteau il y avait un manteau aussi
blanc que la cime du mont fuji
cette folie c'est non et je vois très
bien ce que vous avez essayé de faire
d'ailleurs
puis intenté commença de votre ami a
essayé de nous provoquer en jouant sur
notre sens de l'honneur comme si les
samouraïs et est obligé de répondre à
n'importe quel défi j'ai fait ça moi
j'ai seulement dit que j'allais vous
tuer si vous donnez pas ce qu'on va vous
nous avez défié c'est tentant mais non
donc du coup si on vous met au défi je
tenu des données la russie
ce ne sera rien au nom de l'honneur des
sabres a été nous acceptons des samoa
et pareil pour moi
[Musique]
ah oui nous
construite à rennes il ya déjà des
milliers de gens dans les tribunes en
1h11 bar bientôt bientôt écouter c'est
un tournoi en trois matches j'ai inscrit
elliott et la buse dans deux premiers
matches les gagnants des deux combats
s'affronteront pour le combat final
là on gagne et on récupère la relique
très bien donc moi en fait on ne demande
même pas de participer tu vas tu aurais
aimé de battre contre les plus grands
guerriers du japon non non pas du tout
mais j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me demande
ensuite j'aurai refusé parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on fait est là tout le monde
aurait été content
bon tournoi pour gagner la relique
ancestrale torpillé par le grand esprit
remonte aussi blanc que l'acier du mont
fuji tout à fait et pour ce premier
match à coup nous avons sur le contrôle
du match si je peux me permettre
vous pouvez vous le permettre
adversaires sous sol twitchell entre
toutes ses faces le week-end a bondi sur
les lieux dimanche ce week-end c'est
malencontreux seront plantés dans le dos
nos gens nos bons côtés c'est vraiment
pas de chance à valérie ce toi te dire
que tu m'as toujours aimé mais je sais
donc n'ont alors pas du tout je voulais
te dire autre chose pas mal avec les
toiles de ligne jacques planté dans ton
case qui est planté dans mon coeur c'est
mon amour pour toi et tu tombes des
dents ouais t'as pas l'air de trop
souffrir pour arriver à faire des
métaphores aussi naze un web en fait
c'est un truc qui m'a protégé dans la
baisse
c'est fou les clés d'aliénor comme quoi
il faut toujours garder les objets dans
son inventaire
thomas va te cacher dans les vestiaires
pour coup parce que même quand tu te
bats pas tu manques de mourir le jeune
homme qui a manqué de mourir rentrer
dans le vestiaire tandis que man truck
sugar omnicast du réseau cuma il sa
campagne et lui donne des dizaines de
goût je ne fais pas blessé cet humain
quoi c'est vrai c'est contraire aux lois
de la robotique de simone
non c'est juste que je fais riz café je
ne suis pas un robot de combat mais on
s'entend café gkb 28
tu peux servir entre est à votre service
et risser à mon ami moudjar aussi
présents ces litres de café brûlant
s'entassent directement d'en saisir
scellés tous les cafés robuste avec
trash au service autonome aux yeux pour
votre bon plaisir
intitulé ils tombent sur la troisième
corde j'ai perdu plein jah gao par
brûlures aux yeux quand on vous disait
que les ninjas n'avait pas froid aux
yeux excellent jeu de mots ou des amis
de faire c'est parti
takeshi le grand amour à la fierté de la
nation contre la buse
le pirate de taille moyenne les
adversaires se saluent le pirate de
taille moyenne se salit go vient de
donner un coup à takeshi commence à lui
il a baissé la tête
bien sûr ce sera un point de pénalité
pour la bulle est un droit qu'à trois
points de pénalité c'est quoi des points
de pénalité
on se bat on invente des mots aussi
c'est bon tu peux y aller maintenant
mais attention aux pirates de taille
moyenne ou 150 s'élance vers le savoir
il fait à iéna que ce qui se passe si
j'ai encore quelqu'un vient d'apparaître
sur le terrain sort du terrain vague
qu'avez-vous dit d'avis et crèches de
l'accusé moi je me bats tu vois pas
revendre plus tard boulot deuxième point
de pénalité pourvu qu habituellement
pouvez vous me parler je ne suis pas
venu ici pour souffrir c'est entendu
c'est très clairement un yoga et qui a
été évoqué très clairement les yôkai
c'est très célèbre aux esprits japonais
tout le monde sait que l'invocation de
yokaï est formellement interdite par le
règlement des tournois pour gagner des
reliques ancestrale confiés par des
grands esprits au menton aussi blanc que
la cime du mont fuji un coup de poing un
gros mot une à vocation de yokaï ça fait
3 pénalités disqualifié ça veut dire que
tu as perdu tu vois je sais quoi je paie
mon bonnet ne pas se battre
c'est takeshi le grand symbole de la
fierté de la nation tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la finale verra s'affronter tarkett chez
le grand amour avec la fierté de la
nation contre elliott attendait pour
bien me donner une information capitale
en quoi encore elliott l'humain mais si
voyons je suis un humain je fais des
trucs d'humains regardez je vais manger
ce litchi miam lycées s effectue son
entrée au moins pu faire l'effort
d'enlever la peau avant apparemment le
moment où 6 litres de liquide bouillon
sont sortis du ventre d'elliot a mis les
arbitres sur la piste pas du tout
j'étais en train de erin et
personnellement j'écoute et c'était pas
du tout les urines pourquoi tu as goûté
ça va c'est bon c'était pas de rennes
quant à goûter ducrocq x glory n'était
pas lui rin et les autres humains
n'étaient pas à lui mais le disqualifier
tout paraît vous des amis qu'est ce
qu'on va faire moi walf grand place
hélas les femmes sont à peine des
humains aussi hissé seul homme de votre
équipe qui ne s'est pas encore battu
peut participer à la finale
on suivra les personnes vous perdez
immédiatement route auront trou alors
allez-vous en remplaçant
thomas
je savais qu'on prononcé comme ça aussi
bonne et lui dire que j'étais dans les
vestiaires j'ai entendu il se passe un
truc il se passe que le prochain épisode
s'annonce épique
un dangereux samouraï fait face à thomas
qui demande de l'aide à sa mère pour
ouvrir les portes cornichons quel combat
excitant
vous découvrirez la fin du tournoi de
vichy jean kina épique
c'est le nom japonais de l'épopée
temporel merci d'avoir écouté le
huitième épisode de l'épopée temporel
n'hésite pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
at abonnés et à la semaine prochaine